should we be displaying this Mr chairman
get a ladies should we be displaying
this Mr chairman this is obscene this is
pornographic you hear the Democrat off
camera yelling and screaming and crying
because Marjorie green is showing
censored pictures of Hunter Biden
engaging in an oral sex act I totally
agree with the criticism it's obscene
it's pornographic it has no place in the
House of Representatives but
unfortunately today those same people
who are raising all of those objections
they're insisting that more graphic
displays of even more obscene and
depraved sexual acts belong in
Elementary School classrooms